there's still a way out uh it's still
with russia uh there is there is a
diplomatic roots
uh and we strongly strongly encourage
russia to to to take that route um but
there is that build-up of troops on the
border there is no actual uh
evidence of it of it of it coming down
no no sign of it
uh dissipating um so so that threat is
there and you use the word imminent it
might be imminent or it might take a
little bit longer um you know we're
dealing with uh we're dealing with a
regime here in in president putin who
will who
may pick his moments but we have to
stand strong we stand
shoulder-to-shoulder uh with uh with our
friends in the ukraine we're very clear
that were there to be a further
incursion and invasion from russia that
would be very bad it would obviously be
very bad for ukraine it'd be bad for
europe and it would also be bad for for
russia
because of because of what will follow
we want to be working with russia one of
the great nations of the of the world on
all these big challenges we face
globally uh we don't want russia to be
outside that family of nations and with
the sanctions regime and so on that
would be necessary so strongly encourage
president putin uh to step back and
choose that diplomatic route
okay well the diplomacy will continue as
we watch what's happening on that border
but we'll have you minister i must speak
to you about the pandemic as well there
is a decision now to live with covid
that decision by government has been
criticized by nhs leaders saying that it
might be a risk it's a gamble
are we happy to just live with this
pandemic as we have it now and stop
giving away free lateral flow tests
well i mean
of course we are going to have to learn
to deal with to live with as as you say
with with covert as it moves from
pandemic to to endemic and there will be
an announcement um about about exactly
how we will
uh uh how we will go about that but you
know there's bit we've been putting in
huge investments in this country in
particular in in the vaccination program
that that is our
you know that is the number one uh part
of our defense uh against uh against
this precisely minister that's what you
can do precisely but the nhs
confederation say that this government
move is too gung ho do you disagree with
what the nhs leaders are saying well we
i think we wait to see what the what
what the government's an announcement is
in full on on what all we are going to
do
to uh to to to live with this virus as
we must as as commander we live with
other uh other viruses other illnesses i
mean just yesterday of course there was
the further announcements on the
availability of vaccination for
uh for younger children and we're now
you know over 90 of the over of the over
12 uh population having had that
vaccination this country has been
absolutely in the vanguard
of uh of investing in of of innovating
for uh of making sure that we can cope
with with what has been of course is
terribly destructive
uh a virus uh but we are now coming to
the stage where where yes of course we
we must prepare uh to live with it
uh okay then mr well we've got you a
couple more questions please if we can
there's been reporting this morning that
alexander downer former foreign minister
from australia is going to be advising
the government on immigration policy mr
downer as you will know was responsible
for the push back policy in australia
you in support of pushing migrants back
in the channel
so i've met mr i met mr mr downer he's
doing a review into the operation of uh
of border force which of course is that
is the force which
uh you know it looks after our border
security at you know at the front end uh
what's happening at the end of the
threat of the border in terms of
illegal immigration organized
immigration crime but also good
smuggling uh some sometimes uh goods and
cash leaving the country illegally um or
all of these things that threat is
constantly
evolving it's changing and so it's right
that we
it's right that we review it uh exactly
how we go about those things and i think
having
having a you know a different
perspective
fresh eyes looking at that i think is is
a sensible thing to do
okay damien hines security minister
uh thank you for joining us this morning
thank you very much good morning to you